in this course we're going to move
towards a new way of looking at verbs
this way is different from the concept
of verbs we talked about in the
introduction to the grammar of words in
those lessons we treated verbs as a sort
of action word but something else comes
out when we put verbs in the context of
sentences let's look at the verb give in
a sentence like I gave it to him one
thing you'll notice is that we have
three noun phrases I it and a
prepositional phrase to him which
includes the pronoun him let's start
replacing these nouns with other nouns
we can switch them outright we can say
John gave it to him John gave the bone
to him John gave the bone to the dog
we're still fine there the sentence
makes sense when we switch out noun
phrases and insert new ones ad hoc but
what happens when we start switching out
that verb notice that we can say I gave
it to him or I said it to him but I
bought it to him and I slept it to him
give us some trouble we don't tend to
hear sentences like that in English if
you're a native English speaker you
probably don't think that the verb makes
much sense in that context so there's a
fundamental asymmetry here between nouns
and verbs the verb is doing something
that's in a way more central than those
nouns how do we describe this well
instead of defining the verb as a word
that talks about an action we can move
to describing it as the essential
function word in a sentence in fact it
almost seems to lay out the central
structure of the sentence that we expect
to find used including the number and
type of nouns used
over the next few lessons we're going to
take a look at the number and type of
nouns and pronouns that get used with
different verbs I said that the verb is
a function word and that function word
takes arguments for example the verb
give requires three arguments as you
continue along you'll learn what it
means to say that give requires three
arguments and that those three arguments
are of different types
you